it is not often a mother has to lead her
cub away from the pride
but it happens
this is gibson who has already lost a
brother
his mother knowing what might happen if
they return is always on the lookout
there's a thread out there
this is paula
[Music]
he is currently the strongest and oldest
male courting the females of the pride
and he does not want gibson with the
rest of his cubs
[Music]
competition between males is strong and
they don't want cubs from other males in
their territory
[Music]
so while growing up male lions are only
safe as long as their father is still in
the picture
[Music]
this could have been gibson's brothers
and sisters since they are part of the
same pride
but since gibson's father is gone this
territory now belongs to paula and his
coalition of two other males
[Music]
gibson already lost a brother to paula
and the new male coalition
and paula might come kill him if he gets
the chance
[Music]
this is why gibson's mother has led him
away from the pride away from paula
[Music]
to keep him alive
but away from the pride there's never a
safe moment
[Music]
[Music]
being part of the pride they had
strength in numbers
[Music]
being exiles from the pride
they don't stand a chance against a
five-ton elephant
[Music]
in time gibson will be old enough to
find other males and form a coalition of
his own
but for now he will have to try to steer
clear of the ruling males
and stick with his mother
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you